hey what is up guys mkbhd here and 2015
was a great year plenty of dope tech
came out during the year 2015. so
instead of saying 2015 was the year of
the blank insert cliche here let's not
put it into a box like that too much
awesome stuff came out so we're gonna
round up all of that stuff this video
will serve as a hub for everything you
need to know about the year that just
happened in tech so number one
smartphones they're kind of everywhere
plenty of people have them now and we
got a bunch of awesome smartphones
released in 2015. their performance got
better their features got better their
cameras got better they got better in a
lot of ways and it would be hard to go
wrong with any of the top few choices of
course i made an entire separate video
the smartphone awards 2015. boom the
card is right there that video details
all the stuff you need to know regarding
all the phones released this year then
there were also tablets and i also made
an entire video about those tablets
because they had a bit of a weird year
in 2015 i guess as far as progress goes
that's not to say they were bad we still
got some really good ones ipad air 2
ipad pro pixel c from google surface pro
4 but they definitely had a confused
trend going on as far as the
functionality goes so you should watch
that video too and then there were
wearables the technology that you
actually wear on yourself and 2015 was
the year of the second wave of smart
watches including the first apple
smartwatch called the apple watch and of
course we have that alongside others
like the moto 360 version 2 the moto 360
sport and similar smart watches from
others pretty much everyone got into the
game in the last two years everywhere
from huawei to actual watchmakers like
tag huer these pretty much all do way
more than your average fitness band
since they talk to your phone and they
show your notifications and stuff but
that's the thing is they're definitely
all still smartphone accessories not
standalone devices by
themselves of the point it was also kind
of cool to see android wear show up on
the iphone this year now virtual reality
takes a few steps forward every year and
this was no exception we got new stuff
from samsung in the gear vr and google
cardboard these being the headsets that
actually use the display in your
smartphone to deliver that immersive
experience but the standalone headsets
also advanced so we got new oculus rift
a new sony playstation vr previously
known as project morpheus and htc vive
which i got hands on time with this
stuff is definitely still niche though
so the hardware required to make a good
quality vr experience aside from i guess
google cardboard is pretty expensive for
the limited functionality nevertheless
early adopters of virtual reality stuff
are more than willing to drop a few
hundred bucks to give this emerging tech
a shot some other things you should know
about
force touch force touch and 3d touch
became sort of out of the blue a really
big deal for apple and their whole
ecosystem this year so 3d touch is
software reacting to different levels of
pressure from your finger so the new
iphone 6s and 6s plus have 3d touch
displays and apps are being built to
take advantage of it force touch is just
two levels of pressure it's a hard force
press or a lighter one but it's the same
idea more pressure equals a different
function so we saw that in stuff like
the apple watch the new macbook trackpad
the macbook pros that came out and the
new magic trackpad 2. these are all
small surfaces but i would expect to see
pressure sensitivity in larger surfaces
like an ipad next year and i wouldn't be
surprised to see 3d touch used to make a
big design change in the iphone 7 in
2016 just saying so yeah keep an eye on
pressure sensitivity i think that's
honestly apple's big innovation of this
year usb type-c if you don't know now
you know it's new it's awesome it's here
to stay it's the newest generation usb
port so reversible carries more power
carries faster data and already this
year we see it in a couple smartphones
tablets and laptops and their
accessories we already saw it this year
in a couple smartphones nexus 6p nexus
5x one plus two we start to see it in
tablets the google pixel c we saw some
from asus and from dell and then most
notably the new macbook now when you
look at the new macbook with just one
port that solo lonely usb c port and
then an 80 adapter needed to do anything
other than charge it it does seem kind
of weird and behind but i can pretty
much guarantee that the next generation
macbook will have more than one of these
ports hopefully a few and expect a bunch
more smartphones to have this port in
2016. the later adopters might be guys
like apple with their lightning for a
while and samsung sticking with micro
usb but down the road usb-c it'll happen
it'll happen now i've got to give props
to windows 10 which was a pretty great
improvement from microsoft this year
specifically the hardware lineup they
have out for now it's never really had
like a nexus name but you could say the
surface lineup out now is the nexus of
windows 10 hardware so you have your
surface book the laptop plenty of pros
and cons to that guy but it's high end
in its own right then the surface pro 4
as your tablet and then of course you
have a lumia 950 xl as your highest end
windows 10 smartphone and continuum
which has a nice way of them all talking
to each other also thanks for your
comments my 950 xl is in the mail for
here so that'll be one of the first
smartphones i check out for 2016. should
be fun cars
man just seems like the 100 year old car
industry is always a little bit behind
when it comes to the tech stuff but 2015
was
solid and 2016 is promising i'm a big
fan personally of two things in cars one
electric cars and two
self-driving or autonomous cars which is
probably why i'm such a big fan of the
tesla model s so here's a fun fact about
the tesla model s alright so it's a
really high-end electric car and it's a
really high-tech car so it's got its own
internet connection it can download
software updates on the fly to improve
its feature set and the way it drives
and each individual model s with the
adaptive cruise control and self
steering which combined to be called
autopilot mode it kind of learns the
roads you drive so let's say you're in a
model s and you take a new curve with
autopilot on and it's a really tight
curve so it has to slow down a little
bit it takes a little too fast it'll
beep at you a little bit tell you to
take the steering wheel it didn't really
quite get it right that time
that's something it'll learn for the
next time you come around that on the
map and you do it again the second time
it'll slow down a little earlier it'll
take the curve a little slower probably
won't beep at you probably won't take it
too fast and we'll start to understand
the curve a little better so the third
time the fourth time the fifth time that
you take that curve maybe it's in your
daily commute the car is learning it and
eventually we'll do it just perfectly
it'll slow down hug it perfectly and
exit the curve like a normal driver and
that's awesome but tesla model s kind of
treats itself like part of a fleet of
every single tesla model so it sends
that data up to the network and then on
your next software update when you
download that software update everyone
else's tesla model s will get those
improvements to that part of the road so
if i drive by there a week later and
i've never seen that part of the road
before on autopilot my car already knows
to slow down a little early and take
that curve nice and tight because the
person before me did it and their car
learned it that's pretty dope alright so
one more thing tech on youtube did
really well again this year plenty of
new channels plenty of new communities
new people to talk to you about tech and
i always kind of have numbers to support
this so of the 86 videos that i uploaded
to youtube all about tech in the last
year over a thousand years of human life
were spent watching them even more than
the 2014 numbers which were already
pretty ridiculous so it's kind of cool
to see tech on youtube still growing and
tech video flourishing on the internet
so in summary 2015
was pretty dope
2016 has a tough fact to follow but i
think we're up for it thanks for
watching
i'll talk to you guys next year
peace